le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
lorsque l'on est âgées malades ou
handicapées
il devient parfois impossible de vivre
seul comment éviter l'hospitalisation ou
les maisons de santé lorsque l'on
souhaite conserver un cadre familial le
département propose réunionnais le
dispositif de famille d'accueil
une solution qui permet aux personnes
âgées de loger chez l'habitant dans des
conditions chaleureuse pour les familles
accueillantes c'est aussi un moyen de
créer de l'emploi dans les hauts de la
possession sabine héberge monsieur
frotter depuis presque un an
c'est à dos d'âne que depuis un an
sabine nativel partage sa maison et son
quotidien avec philippe frotter après
avoir enchaîné les petits boulots
pendant plusieurs années elle découvre
le dispositif départemental des familles
d'accueil jeu quand même toujours été
entourée de personnes âgées
je suis quand même toujours occuper les
grands parents d'emma midi tout ça donc
j'ai fait en train de galérer un petit
peu pour trouver du travail aussi et par
jean imbs revient après une demande
d'agrément
sabine rencontre monsieur frotter
hospitalisé suite à un avc il ne peut
plus vivre seul et n'a pas de famille
sur l'île
la famille d'accueil est venu me voir
c'est passé demi journée avec eux et
puis ensuite ils ont dû décider
oui on veut bien de feu aux lilas et
entre l'impassible maîtresse des lieux
et son résident à l'humour caustique
il faut alors apprendre à vivre ensemble
et que j'ai eus poissons deux ans ici je
suis déjà disons 30 indépendant alors
quand on dit même monsieur il faut faire
ça tu vois ça s'accroche mais madame
nativel avec sa diplomatie habitués
arrivent à passer la pilule si c'est un
peu comme un couple il faut qu'on
il faut que nous on apprenne à bien
connaître d habitude de me frotter faut
que monsieur frotter l'apprennent à bien
connaître nos habitudes amour pour une
cohabitation réussie des formations et
un suivi sont assurés par le département
on a quand même un soutien on est quand
même l'aider
dans dents parce que c'est peut-être pas
toujours évident mais on apprend quand
même beaucoup de choses dans les
formations dans la chambre de monsieur
frotter sabine a voulu recréer un
environnement familier et rassurant
tous les éléments de décoration
appartiennent tous sexagénaires ou
encore bijoux avec les tableaux qui les
terres qui étaient dans ma chambre
on essaie quand même de rester un petit
peu ce que lui vous avez installé par la
famille nativel donc oui je suis tombé
sur un bal famine pour pouvoir héberger
des personnes âgées ou handicapées
sabine a dû aussi réalisé quelques
travaux elle bénéficie d'une aide
départementale à l'amélioration de
l'habitat pour aménager sa salle de bain
pour le déplacement faudrait que ce soit
plus pratique
15h30 comme tous les jours monsieur
frotter s'installe sur la terrasse fidel
castro mais je viens au pkk utilisé mon
endroit préféré je vois suivi naba le
cerbère de la maison et je vois les deux
les petits sacs qui se bagarrent avons
beaucoup de nouveaux c'est aussi le
moment de la journée où la maisonnée
reçoit de la visite se portaient très
bien
on désire groupe d mirella une voisine
vient souvent discuté avec le
pensionnaire de sabine moi
personnellement ça me fait plaisir
voilà je suis très social donc allé
rendre visite à ces personnes là bas ça
m'apporte beaucoup aussi quoi le fait de
lâcher pas de dernier les voix de
raconter des histoires de d'échanger
quelques sourires
est ce important pas pendant ce temps en
cuisine
la propriétaire prépare le goûter du
fromage kiri dessus aujourd'hui oui oui
oui
puis même bien taquiner les cours autour
de petites douceurs l'après-midi
s'achève dans la bonne humeur et la
convivialité
un vrai moment de partage familial
en 2015 le département disposer de 1166
places réparties dans 5 174 familles
d'accueil
l'accueil familial a toujours été une
priorité donc pour le département de
plus en plus sur les personnages et donc
ne peuvent plus se maintenir seul à
domicile doublette l'intervention donc
de l'accueillant familial pour aider ces
grammont à accomplir les gestes de
chaque jour les grammy c'est le pilier
de la société réunionnaise
c'est grâce à notre amour qu aujourd'hui
nous nous sommes là donc je pense que la
moindre des choses c'est de les
respecter et de les aimer
l'accueil familial est un dispositif
pour les personnes âgées ou handicapées
qui ne peuvent plus vivre seul et qui
souhaitent conserver des liens sociaux
et familiaux dans un logement adapté les
personnes qui peuvent bénéficier de
l'accueil familial doivent être âgés de
plus de 60 ans et ne pas avoir de lien
de parenté avec la famille accueillante
les personnes qui souhaitent devenir
accueillant doivent être majeurs seuls
ou en couple et agréés par le
département pour plus d'informations sur
les modalités et les demandes d'agrément
vous pouvez vous adresser à la direction
des personnes âgées et handicapées
2 rue de la source 97 1488 à saint-denis
où vous rendre sur le site du
département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
m